hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the key
concepts as needed in order to make
sense of Mills moral theory qualitative
utilitarianism is his conception of
ideal judges of the people who would
actually be qualified to say in
determinate instances which pleasures
are higher in which pleasures are lower
now in the absence of them you have at
least with this theory some guidelines
you know the higher faculties the
pleasures of the higher faculties are
better pleasures qualitatively better or
satisfying more enjoyable than those of
the lower pleasures of merely have the
pleasure to the sensibility or curiosity
but we want it we want to have something
that's a bit firmer basis and so Mill
says who should we ask about this what
we need with respect to choosing between
two pleasures we need judges that they
actually experience both of the
pleasures so if it's a question of you
know two different kinds of food we need
people who've actually tried
it's food it's a question somebody
trying they're trying why'd they have to
choose between those they have to
actually appreciate the air for its on
saving life for its own sake if it's
somebody who is going to judge between
going to the wine bar I'm going out to
tavern or going to the night opera or a
rock concert or you know we can think
whatever things we want throw a lot of
things into the mix in order to make an
informed judgment about this you have to
have some experience and it can't just
be a sort of dip your toe in kind
experience that they're thorough
experience they have to open themselves
up to the possibilities so proves
stick-in-the-muds will not make good
ideal judges and pleasures they are not
the people to go to you need somebody
who's actually had quite an experience
and mill says that when you're trying to
decide between two fighters you want to
look at which of those pleasures is
preferred by all or if you can't get
complete unanimity on it most of those
who have as fully as possible experience
both pleasures do also want to set aside
any previous moral considerations
because what are you trying to figure
out is actually which is more valuable
yeah insult Arianism what makes it moral
is that it involves the greater or a
better pleasure for everybody who's
involved as much as possible so you'd be
a perfect example of that if we have a
culture in which say pornography is seen
as morally wrong or objectionable
shame or desire you would want and you
want to decide consuming pornography or
engaging in intimacy with another person
developed over time you know if it's a
courtship and that involving sex which
of these pleasures should I prefer
because they're both you know fun in
their own ways right
and the ideal judges with set aside and
previous moral considerations have
nothing has to be people who'd actually
looked at pornography and you know used
it for the mmm that it's used for and
we've also been in full-blown you know
relationships that involve sexual
expression and then you would look at
what in fact they do in fact prefer
after they said sign that you sort of
well I think I should prefer this you
want to see what do they actually prefer
and know would say in this case most
likely they're gonna prefer the intimate
relationship with another person why
well community says on two pleasures
there be the one to which all or almost
all of the experience both give a
decided preference irrespective in a
feeling of moral obligation prefer it
that is the most desirable pleasure if
one of the two is by those who are
competently included with both place so
far above the other they prefer it
even though knowing it to be attended
with a greater amount of discontent and
would not resign it for any quantity the
other pleasure we are justified in this
fragment of the preferred enjoyment a
superiority and while far outweighing
quantity as to render it and comparison
of small account a little bit later he
says very much the same thing basis from
this verdict of the only competent
judges I African there can be no appeal
on a question which is the best which is
the best worth having of two pleasures
or which two modes of existence so it's
not just individual pleasures is ways of
life it's its ways of committing one's
self to to pleasure to pain
which is the most grateful to the
feelings of parchments moral attributes
and from its consequences the judgment
of those who are qualified by knowledge
of both or if they differ that at the
majority upon them must be admitted as
final so you have some people who are
qualified to make these sorts of
judgments because they have in fact
enjoyed these pleasures they plumb that
as far as they could and now they can
say yeah I like this better than this
I'm a middle doesn't spell this mo but
they probably should be able to give you
reasons as well this just mirror yea or
nay or up or down or you know plus one
this way yeah yeah there's a so this is
a pretty easy concept to get what would
be some of the implications of this for
one young people would not be
particularly good judges not just of
individual pleasures but you know how to
blade cleansers against each other in
part because they haven't experienced
quite as much as would be desirable to
make them make them good judgments now
what the person need to be a connoisseur
and when we say connoisseur we mean
somebody who's very comfortable working
for knowledge kind of song soon in
French right I meet somebody who
thoroughly know something so for example
I drink coffee and I you know I'm sort
of beginner to intermediate level when
it comes to like differentiating the
case I just drink coffee cos I'm Joanna
there are people out there who can tell
you
ah that's this being most of them this
way came from that series when took
place with that and they can describe
all sorts of things that go in
not only know things about the taste
they don't think about the history of
the beam they you know that raises
things to a higher level right when you
need that level of connoisseur chef in
order to in order to be an ideal judge
probably not unless you're getting down
to very nitty-gritty stuff and then
you're actually notice then that you're
probably dealing with things that are
already a higher a higher level of
pleasures and you're transferring which
one is which one is more intense so if
you're going to film the credits in your
ask them which is a better film literary
critics pot novels you're dealing with
things that are actually all on the same
plane you're not actually comparing that
to a grapefruit sail now it's
interesting when we get to foods by the
way I advise you to check out like my
course video where I had a chef a minute
sort of guest lecturer back and forth
about this talking specifically about
male higher pleasures judges and got
access and food there's something that
mill would usually place at lower level
the wanting the Sensibility I would
argue that food and at least certain
kinds of drinks can be brought up to a
higher level where they actually engage
the intellect perhaps of Moral
Sentiments feeling and imagination these
higher faculties that no one's talking
about probably not to the extent that a
novice or even a great film does because
there are different types of Arts
certainly not to the level of that a
great intimacy with a friend or a lover
either but once we reach this higher
level then when we're talking about you
know connoisseurs or experts we're
talking about the difference
Tencent well we're really worried about
here are higher and lower in the sense
of being able to say this pleasure is
determinately qualitatively better than
this one this is something that we
shouldn't avoid if we can get our hands
on it but if we have to sacrifice it
more than this this has to go
the ideal judges are the ones or
qualified to do that
you know so for example to take up the
question pornography yet if in fact and
there's a lot of discussion about this
and I'm going to leave this an open
question but I'm going to show you what
bill wouldn't make into this if in fact
using pornography regularly makes it
harder for a person to have genuine
intimacy with another person because
there's certain the facts that take
place all sorts of discussions about
this then they're required to choose
between these two pleasures yeah
if the ideal judges would say intimacy
is better then you get rid of the porn
you can say the same thing about like
you know listening to crappy music made
it impossible that was just purely
satisfying the senses made made it
impossible sort of like destroying a
musical palette for you to enjoy the
higher pleasures of music get rid of the
crappy music some other things that we
want to think about here there is a sort
of element of trust or apprenticeship
required in order to become an ideal
judge we're going to rely on an ideal
judge yeah you know again you can think
of kind of sewer isn't that our trust
that we place in that ultimately they
would say what to do me to experience
you want to try to move towards being a
good judge yourself now what would
interfere with being
good judge what would be you know
organic accessibility not being able to
taste things could actually a huge
detriment not being able to that can be
able to come to the surgery by the
imagination you know or my intellect you
think of Beethoven of the fact that he
could compose even death because he
generated habits and a whole mental map
of it is mine music but you know and
Sensibility Cueto often is not an
organic problem it's a it's coming from
you know prudishness or unwillingness to
try new things stick with it and here's
a great example there's a rule of thumb
for kids I was not a picky eater I would
just about anything except for facts
about the texture most other things I
play vinicky kids you're supposed to
give them the dish that you're having
them try and learn to appreciate ten
times because it takes that one to break
down the conditioning of do the FMO need
for them to actually try that and see
whether they can derive some pleasure
that's a lower right but insensibility
lack of experience and this could derive
or not not being in forward to the
opportunity to enjoy pleasures addiction
the lower pleasures can milk locks about
this actually a little bit when we
become addicted to lower pleasures that
may cut us off from the possibility
eventually giving ourselves fully to
higher pleasures and therefore being
able to judge them and then it's hard to
what a lot of social factors
talks about what he calls bad an
imperfect social institutions I'll give
you a great example of this if you come
from a society where intellectual effort
is laughed at or treated as being a nerd
or a geek or you know could actually
dangerous for you then you're not going
to be in a good condition to truly give
yourself to literature some people will
still do that because they'll react
against America you can screw you you're
not gonna keep me from reading this but
a lot of you I see this with a lot of
students but I have a lot of students
are very afraid of being smart I've
actually indulging and developing their
intellects and their imaginations
it's particularly bad when it comes to
math I think that anybody who says I'm
just bad at math really they ought to do
more now because you don't really know
and this excuse oh I just been trying to
do that over in Europe and people look
at you like wow practice them try it out
some more because it's a it's a it's a
compound but we allow people to get away
with that and if you've never actually
experienced the the joy of seeing the
elegance of a mathematical proof because
that's why you learn to do to see that
you're not going to appreciate it you're
not going to be a competent job it's the
same thing with you know say learning
foreign languages is it worth it to
learn foreign language or not you know
you want to learn more than just being
able to order and bar or find the
bathroom you want to actually be able to
read the literature and appreciate the
music the language learn something about
its history see the world through
different eyes that only becomes
possible if you actually put in the work
for that you know reading Plato agreed
it's very different
translation that took a lot of work and
you can only appreciate that if you
actually are able to you know carry out
that that development so you can't be an
ideal judge some things unless you've
actually lent yourself to it and like no
sense you know social factors can
interfere with that a lot it's tough to
engage in that
you gotta constantly hustle to make a
buck of money on the table to you know
get up the next day to do it yeah and he
talks about that in Arizona in Chapter
two a few other places as well so those
were things I could interfere with a
person becoming an ideal judge and you
could say that well that's unfair
you know everybody should be able to
judge Milas more with Socratic in this
sentence but he's being aristocratic
because he thinks that this really
matters it's important to get right
which pleasures are actually in
themselves more enjoyable for human
beings when they fully that you know are
ready to appreciate those pleasures so
that's his theory of the ideal judge